hi today i'd like to talk about
uh a film that i put out recently
saying does your aikido work
perhaps i am uh perhaps i'm a deeper
thinker than
a lot of people like no idea you know
we're all individuals when we
have a job knowing ourselves
and even if we know ourselves it's
difficult
to uh correct things if we can't see
them
now my tai chi master
mr faye who presented me with this book
it's a book of his life really
and it's a beautiful book now he was uh
they say a professor rather than a
master in
if i remember correctly 18 different
wushu martial arts in china
and what he done was he traveled all
over china
i only learned from him tai the tai chi
24 form 42 form
the sword forms but he
showed me many what i considered were
aikido techniques
and i was devastated when i thought that
i sensed it made them
it wasn't that i was young in
martial arts at all it was in the
beginning of the 90s
and i started when i was in 1973 so
a long time then all of a sudden this
this
wonderful man takes me to one side in
his
living room and he shows me
koshinagi and ikea i was devastated i
took me ages before i didn't want to
walk away from aikido and just
think that i sense he was a fraud i'm
holding it here because you would have
seen
this picture of him jumping high
with the sword okay now
i went to see him in china
and i want to talk about um
does aikido work
but there's more to it than that i don't
know
what uh women think
but as a man i know that we have a big
ego
problem especially when we're young
and it's as if we put on our giddy and
we're some kind of
superman
and we believe in this dream world that
there's this
super human power that we can
call upon at any time and we spend most
of our
martial career searching for it when's
it gonna come what do i have to do to
perfect this how do i call upon this
mass power
said before that i sense he said that
kojita he was his finest student
he learned this mass power and there's
one technique where you'll see something
trying to lift him
and the next minute he tries to get him
he can't lift him
since toy scentsy
sorry tides he taps the person on the
head he collapses
i've done this on a very very large
person
in russia his legs went to jelly
and he collapsed sometimes in these
films i shall repeat myself what i've
said in other films but
it's just because i'm going searching
back in my memory
i've talked about my book and um
this isn't it's a plug for the book but
it's not really
it's it's to talk about
does your aikido work for you and and
what it what i've been told is
it does i
like most sensors who have been around a
while will get invited to teach in
dojos around the world locally
and you arrive there they've got a
completely different start perhaps what
you're doing
and you're looking at them and you're
thinking i've only got one night here
or one day or one weekend if i start
pulling
their aikido apart will they thank me
or will they just think that i'm
completely so
off the wall with my thoughts but
they're never going to invite me back
again well when you're younger you want
to be invited back
so you tend to praise them and
try and slip in the more important
points as you
see them i'm being really honest with
you here you know
i'm as bad as i've been as bad as
anybody
but wanting my ego polished
now i've got nothing to lose because
um i'm not at the end of my life but i'm
at the end of my chasing my
ego my dreams i found in like you know
everything
that i want to find and now i want to
just build on what i found
i was in china with mr frey
and he met me at the top of this
hotel and the reason
he wanted to do that was because he
didn't want the chinese students to see
him teaching a foreign person
but what was more interesting is he
bought his sword
and i didn't speak japan chinese or
him speak english so but we could
communicate it was almost like
we telepathically know what each other's
saying
so he
he has his sword draws it takes it out
the scabbard
stands there right in front of me as
close as i am to you this camera
and he says tony
watch me by the time he'd take his
fingers
back the picture i've just shown you
he was in that pose above my above my
head
and i'm five foot ten i don't know what
it is in centimeters
about 1.8
he was above my head not level with me
and
all i can remember is looking up and
down and i don't know why he done it
no idea at all he was in his early 50s
so that evening i said to his daughter
how did mr faye do that it's incredible
he's talking to me telling me to watch
him next thing
i'm watching him above his head my head
daughter asked him and he said i started
when i was six
and laughed but what he said was
there's no such thing as human power you
just call forth
all your energies all your parts of your
body
you call them together as one
and the onlooker like me watching them
go above my head from
a nothing start didn't even didn't even
go
down to get any spring
how can you do that and he said well
after doing a demonstration or after
doing competition
i have to go and lay down and have a
rest
i said what do you mean you you should
you've got all this
power and he said i'm a human being
i haven't got that power i just caught
upon it
to do the demonstration
so any of you who are dreaming of
being superhuman or calling upon
superpower
and being able to call upon it hour
after hour
forget it you call upon it when it's
needed
so to me that is what makes it important
but what you can't do is you cannot call
upon
it unless the technique
is correct the technical part has to be
correct
so going back to one night when i'm
teaching being invited to this
club the teacher follows
the techniques of lama but the students
who had come from other
dojos other clubs around the area
so there was a mixture of styles on the
in the in the club that night
so i go up to this black belt and i said
to him that
coat of guys wouldn't work
he looked at me said it works for me
i said but what do you mean it works for
you he said well that worked for me
works for me in my club wherever i go it
works for me
so this pricked my ego of my
judgmental mind and i decided that
uh i said but where does it work where
do you go and he said well i go on all
the seminars of our organization
uh i said that's why it works because
you're all doing the same
techniques
i'm going to make this in two parts
the next part of this film i shall go
into
a little bit more detail i want to start
talking technical
and after the cove it is gone hopefully
next year we can start touching again
i will go into detail about taijitsu
but i will talk about things so that
those of you are interested
in finding out if you want to call upon
superhuman power you need to have the
technical
parts correct because power
going through a large pipe
means the volume will be lost power
going through a small
tube but the same amount of power
applied
will have a lot more effect and this is
what you're doing when you're applying a
color guys
and nico and all the various techniques
that one would call upon
thank you for listening and i'll carry
on again more technical
shortly please subscribe